today on game life ubiquitous internet
presents Veronica Belmont she's
everywhere and now we've got her here
welcome to the game live video podcast
today we got a very special guest with
us she is the host of shows such as
tekzilla and factor fictional it's
Veronica Belmont will first thank you so
much for being here we're so happy to
have you you are gaming royalty your mom
was a VP yeah Coleco she was well she
was VP of corporate communications but
she was in charge of all the campaigns
for colecovision and yeah so I had I had
a clear vision way back when I got a lot
of toys I've had like every Cabbage
Patch Kid I did I did we actually we
still have a basement full of Cabbage
Patch Kids which is kind of creepy like
their eyes are looking into my soul but
it was a very cool cool way to grow up
and that really Gil I kind of kicked off
my love of video games as a kid so how
is that manifesting itself today kind of
what are your gaming tastes what are you
playing I'm still an infinite I'm still
playing pow so we won't talk don't no
spoilers oh yeah no no BioShock Infinite
spoilers because you guys it's been a
long time coming yet your stuff together
babe totally well I actually kind of
started a bit of a firestorm on Twitter
because I started talking about the the
race elements in the game and how you
know a lot of reviewers made kind of a
big to-do about how forward-thinking it
was that they introduced race as a theme
when a lot of other video games don't do
that but I found it to kind of be a
shallow take on it more of a set piece
rather than an issue that was being
dealt with and people wasn't really
supposed to be dealt with it's just
supposed to be a sign at the times which
I understand but then I think people
maybe should have made that much of a
you ain't about it the fact that it's
being engaged in in any at any level in
gaming I think yeah I said that as well
next week so uh race is one of those
things what isn't being dealt with in
gaming for you what would you like to
see more of oh that's a really good
question we asked the hard one yeah you
know I think we are we're seeing a few
more strong female leads it's a lot of
games I'm really excited for beyond two
souls and and yeah
yeah The Last of Us and things like that
where it seems like there's really
strong female characters in the main
storyline of course Lara do you guys say
Laura Laura I say Laura when I first
read the name I must have been like 15
years old 14 years old right so it's
burned in your head in like that's how
you you deal with it there's people who
today say Mary oh you know and those
people I think should just be executed
okay yeah it's fine like that's pretty
dark mmm a little dark for for Mario I'm
being I'm talk yeah so I wanted to ask
you is there any anything on your wish
list for the next generation you know
I'm just looking for more immersive I
mean that's at the end of the day that's
kind of what my ultimate end game is for
for consoles anything that makes my
gaming experience more immersive
anything that makes me feel more like
I'm you know in this experience is good
for me I am a little concerned about the
always-on type stuff you know I
understand the necessity for an
always-on scenario when you're watching
streaming content or if you're you're
doing a multiplayer game obviously you
need to be on the internet but for
single-player campaigns and
single-player modes you know we've we've
seen that not go over so hot on the PC
side recently and and you know with with
EA in the past and so hopefully that
won't be so much of a technological
hurdle going forward right so so many
questions that hopefully we're gonna get
answered really soon as we get closer
and closer to e3 maybe even a Microsoft
event later this month but we have been
talking here the game life video podcast
with Veronica Belmont geek royalty and
star of tekzilla and star of many oh
yeah and you have a mayor like one and a
half million Twitter followers so if you
want to add yourself to the giant
shambling horde that is Veronica Belmont
Twitter crowd that's at Veronica it is
yes
Veronica Belmont hardest working person
in technology check her out
this has been the new game live video
podcast for Wired I want to thank our
guests Veronica Belmont if you stick
around we're gonna have Jonathan Blow on
and then all four of us are gonna sit
down and Veronica and Jonathan are gonna
figure out what the deal is with always
online to the death no no no